all right so a special edition of Lada
was credited a and I know when people
think oh this is this is a montage
edition it's like like before happy days
went away right before the jump the
shark wasn't montage but this is
actually something that we haven't done
before but a lot of people have asked me
to talk about some of my favorite guests
that we've had in the show and sometimes
there's a little bit more that's
happened behind the scenes that we just
don't really get to fill and I do have
some favorite guests some standout
guests so we're gonna give you the top
ten guests that have appeared a lot of
this matter and why they're tucked into
main and I'd love to hear from you who
your favorite guests have been or who
you'd like to see on the show comment
below we always want to hear from you so
number 10 a guest I loved having on the
show just because he was such a talk
about a gentle giant World's Strongest
Man four times in the four-time Arnold
Classic Strongest Man so eight times
really uh Bryan Shaw maybe at seven who
cares at this point the point is he's
really strong huge episode 357 he can go
reference in it for Mudd Club members a
lot of these are on YouTube but some of
them are behind Mudd Club only yeah
the full version or sometimes an
extended version and the reason Bryan
Shaw was so interesting to me was
because not only was he big and
obviously strong and intimidating and I
soiled myself but I found I've been
really fortunate to interview excellent
people people who are the matter of fact
I was trying to tell an older relative
about Bryan Shaw she's like well I guess
that would make sense how you're
impressed by him being strong like no
you don't it's not about the strength do
you understand what this guy has done to
achieve this to be the best at anything
and talking with about it you can you
can see a borderline and I mean this is
a good way obsessive personality about
attention to detail and quality and you
see this with any of the people we've
interviewed who were at the top top
level of their field and one thing for
me that really stood out episode 357
with Bryan Shaw I always wanted to ask
this
four-time World's Strongest Man was also
the runner-up more times than anyone
else against his biggest rival wrote the
drona Savickas I think it's how it's
pronounced and poor for the torch was
passed to Bryan Shaw it wasn't even
close this is a journalist guy was in a
league of his own in and Bryan Shaw
Khanna
it a little bit but I asked him you know
he finally just really was
he was as candid as could be and that
was a breakthrough moment in that
interview enjoy you went on to win four
times but like I said the victus was
your main rival and there is a moment I
remember when I was watching world's
strongest camera which year it was but
it was it was a log lift I think it was
the Austrian oak and as far as I
remember it no one else had lifted it
yet some kind of overhead lift and then
I think you were the first one to do it
and you got a rep or two and then I
remember is it victus getting in because
that was his lift listen difference from
it and he just wrapped it out like it
was a like it was a baby again I don't
say that's it because then you went in
you you came back and you won this is
not a slight at all but what was that
moment like for you because it was so
mind-blowing how how strong he wasn't
very specific facets back then sure we I
mean there was I don't know exactly what
moment you're talking about there but
there was definitely times where he had
events especially with the log because
out that's I'm he's been pretty open
saying that's been his favorite lifts by
far overall and so he had those moments
with the log whereas I had kind of those
moments with lifting stones which is
more of kind of my specialty yeah lifts
where you know he couldn't do those
things so in a lot of ways I think
that's what made our rivalry great yeah
is that he had different strengths than
I did and it was always trying to keep
up you know for me keep up with him the
best I could unlike his vet best events
and then the same for him yeah and I
think that we we forced each other to
get better which made it you know it
made it great yeah it really was an area
that was very fun to watch and I just
asked because I always wonder what it's
like to be like the world's the
strongest guy everywhere you go and then
in one event one guy is just you're like
I like it Philippians 1 one word is
frustrating I liked that it was you know
because you put all this hard training
into doing it and then you know if you
go and have an event like that where you
would do so well and I
trained so hard to be better at it it
was just kind of like man you walk away
frustrated from moments like that for
sure
still pretty strong in my book number
nine this is gonna be one that might
surprise some people the first time Nick
DiPaolo was on and this is episode 73 it
was just a big deal for me because he's
one of my favorite stand-up comedians
ever so I grew up watching him and as a
matter of fact when I used to watch him
I would almost feel bad about myself
because I thought I will never ever be
able to achieve with it I will never be
as good of a stand-up comedian as as
Nick DiPaolo huh
I did that enter know in art I would
ever I was drawing when I was younger I
would always like look it like the best
and I'd be like I'm never really go
start smoking crack it's also really
nice to Nick he was really nice I got to
know him on a personal level we spent
like an hour on the phone and he didn't
disappoint it was just bust
I got pee yourself funny so episode 73
it was hard to even pictures take your
pick Nick DiPaolo hysterical it was me
basically meeting one of my comedy idols
do you follow mixed martial arts well I
know your sports guy but do you follow
like the UFC I choked out my wife last
Hillary you know at that black radio
station saying that she had hot sauce oh
my gosh we ran with that we had that
Anna Lou player morphine drip both laugh
she was pandering everybody in the room
know it when they said what are you
carrying a purse they would have had
more respect for her if she said well
thanks to your people I carry mace you
you were right in that mix but yeah
Klein and Carlin and obviously Cosby
until you know the kind of whole rape
thing but there are people like what
happened well you know he raped he raped
the equivalent to a small Haitian
village but shook his hand after show in
Atlantic City but 15 years ago next
thing you know I wake up I'm wearing
nothing but a temple t-shirt instead
there's a bunch of puddin pop rap it's
doctor might know what all right and
clocking in at number eight and you
might think why isn't he higher up on
the list it's just hard to make a list
number two because we have to hear
George st. Pierre episode 134 not only
is he my favorite fighter of volta if I
had to pick one would probably door st.
Pierre and of course because I'm from
from Montreal and all of you their eyes
are glazing over Oh UFC fights it's not
about the sport of fighting it's not
about the UFC if you go watch a
documentary on Georges st. Pierre
there's one called I think the DNA of
George st. Pierre it's done by the same
people do all these Discovery Channel
films like about wolves very very well
done again you realize the same thing
that you see with Bryan Shaw the
consistency with people or at a very
very high level are people who are
self-conscious to a degree but confident
they all realize they could do something
great they said okay I can be the best
at this and then the level of discipline
that most people will never fully
comprehend but my favorite moment from
this in episode 134 George st. Pierre so
he was in the program he couldn't he
couldn't get Skype working so he called
in and there was a special that he did
in the UFC countdown where his
french-canadian mom in French was
complaining when the cameraman came in
saying I don't you know don't show them
my dusty basement so George senior is
known to be a little bit robotic or
stiff because he's very professional a
lot of people don't realize it's just
the way French Canadians are it almost
seems like a fake accent that's how half
of my family sounds and the moment that
stood out to me was when my mom asked
George st. Pierre if the basement was
still dusty and if you can speak fritz
it's hard to fully translate you can
read the subtitles but he relaxes and he
actually goes into talking and it's
almost justifying like none other thing
is my mom was just upset about this and
this is and it became a really personal
conversation between my mom and UFC
legend to possibly you know the best
combat athlete ever George st. Pierre
episode 134 can I ask you mama she has a
question for you in French can you take
one question for she's a superfan okay
man get up
okay so Jody Patel confess software
maja a babysitter cause the the social
calculator capability on jealousy Patna
poor basket see your finished system on
our set or jump estimate the pin-sharp
we don't a stella maeve apology no I
can't easily knows you're a punching bag
at the future
Phoebe's web political panel so nice to
discharge it's gonna be about the
basement because your mom for people who
don't know this is such a
french-canadian thing Josh knows it's
like French Canadians they keep their
houses so clean Jared you know that with
my mom she's like she can't handle it
and Georgeson peers his mom was so mad
and a special that they showed a
basement which was dusty so my mom asked
her was still dusty and George said yes
because they're keeping his a play area
for the kids right yeah they you keep it
for the kid because there's like like a
playground for the kid but if we finish
it I will make like rooms and the walls
and everything is in right now it's it's
gonna be users because we want it to be
for for the kids for the kids but but if
if maybe maybe in a few years when they
grow up we're gonna head because there's
one have to clean it up again because
French Canadians clean up everything as
you're finished eating they came up the
place they say what that's my mom we
were sitting there watching the special
and my mom's like aha she's like poor a
woman I'm like mom are you not watching
the greatest fighter of all time the
countdown is about him fighting her and
she wouldn't stop about the dust in the
basement she's like I want to watch him
is his mother's care about the dust in
the basement I'm going to watch to
support him so by the way the basement
is till dusty number seven Thomas Thomas
soul this was at 3:10 and you know a
couple of reasons why first off this was
the first of the sort of new the newer
media new school podcast to have Thomas
olan he didn't do it
he's a notoriously difficult to book and
then after he did this he started doing
some some more shows I believe and and
really enjoyed his experience he was
just really really easy to work with and
when it comes to economists you'd be
hard-pressed to find someone more
prolific than Thomas ol in our
generation I grew up on him he's a huge
part of my my worldview and how I've
learned economics and he's a huge he's
one of number one recommendations I've
talked about the John Stossel Thomas
soul of course going back to Adam Smith
okay go like that it's a little a little
bit tough it's kind of like going back
and read some old timey Thomas ol brings
it to now and it's it's tough to to pick
a moment but you know what was really
great about Thomas soul was I didn't
expect this you could see him loosen up
and he was actually he was a lot of fun
he was a lot of fun he was very down to
earth and I think we got to see a side
of Thomas well you don't often see so
this is episode 310 Thomas ol how does
it feel to be arguably the most
influential certainly probably the most
influential conservative economist of
our time I know I know you have to be
humble but has it set in I mean because
you're that guy well I I never
contradict the opinions of people who
say say good things about me it would be
impossible to be objective about what
it's why I never tried the impossible
could you maybe expand on most of the
myths that if not for discrimination
society would have equal representation
in careers income education and
incarceration because that's the huge
sort of I guess main tenant of leftism
that's taught on campus if not for
discrimination we'd all have these equal
representation outcomes you put your
finger on the key assumption on which
the holes it's like the Keystone that
holds up the whole structure and you
remove that and they don't have her and
what age is what is one of those things
but what people desire to do matters
right ah you know for all I know I might
have been born you know with genes that
would have enabled me to become another
new Rudolf Nureyev is a male ballet
dancer okay if I was it was a total
waste of genes because where I grew up
nobody it was thought of as well no no
guys ever thought about becoming male
ballet dancers so it doesn't matter what
their abilities were it doesn't matter
whether they were was the opposition or
the gates of opportunity were wide open
they weren't gonna become male ballet
dancer but what people want to do is
huge alright number six this one is what
a lot of you may not even there's no
number to the episode because this is
before remember we actually had episodes
listen it's not before we went daily
it's before this show was a show at all
even as a podcast this is back when we
were on radio and we used to tape our
calls if we could Skype people but we
didn't really know what to do with it so
we finally learned how to record the
Skype video to decent quality and we
started uploading these so this is
actually Carly Fiorina from August's
yeah August 7th 2015 you can search and
on YouTube that's the only place to find
it just Carly Fiorina steven crowder
searched the channel and go through all
of the suggested young turks video
because it'll take you a while 10 do you
realize that half of these interviews
when I was searching through YouTube as
to it my interview with this person is
not even the first thing that pops up no
it's a bunch of random crap with no
views stick everything over like Trent
they're just piling on this it's it's
like a sandwich only there's only word
just the bottom bread every
there's top bread there's a whole layer
of ham and vegetables and then we're
just we're like the saucer plate that's
to snout for the sandwiches we're the
meat no we're not we're the delicious I
mean we want to be the me but not to you
- no not you - don't say delicious meat
on this program Carly so Carly Fiorina
here's why this stands out to me so much
we've been writing about her so a lot of
credit calm a lot of people know who
just watched the show don't realize it's
the website was a lot bigger than the
show for a long time edited by Courtney
Kerr chopped and she still edits over
there wonderful fantastic writer we've
been writing about Carly Fiorina for a
long time I had seen her speak at a
private event and thought wow this
woman's really impressive and then I
watched back then during these primaries
they had the second stage debates people
who didn't necessarily make it to the
the first stage and we were writing
about Carly Fiorina I called her I think
we coined the term the conservative
honey badger and then at one point we
started calling her the conservative
spider monkey on crack because of the
way she went after Katie Couric and so
when we reached out to her people I
thought oh no she I found out she had
heard spider monkey on crack and she
loved it turns out she liked it and she
came on the show so see what she wasn't
doing any any you know any podcasts
Arkansas radio anything like that and
here's why this is so pivotal to me
because what you don't know this when
you watch this interview she gave us
this interview she was at the event
greenroom I believe or another
conference room right before 45 minutes
before she walked on stage that night
and then pulled ahead to number one in
the polls if you remember there was a
moment where Carly Fiorina just pulled
ahead and I will say was kind of it was
mismanaged a little bit by some of the
handlers but no one knew who she was she
came out on stage that night and the
whole world was talking about Carly
Fiorina 45 minutes before that this is
what you see on skype also we got Carly
Fiorina to say that other Republicans
that the males in particular needed to
grow a pair watch clarify your stance so
that no one else is misquoting on
immigration
what would a Carly Fiorina
administration do oh yes number one we
have to secure the border by the way how
long we've been talking about securing
more
years I mean to be accurate the border
has not been secure for 30 years we've
been talking about it for at least 25
it's still not secure so what does that
tell you it tells you politicians talk
talk talk talk talk and yet it never
gets done thanks to area cities you know
how long San Francisco's been a
sanctuary city since 1989 everyone's
gonna get all fired up about this
they're gonna give speeches they're
gonna pass laws and yet nothing really
changes this is why people are fed up
with the political class so number one
secure the border this isn't rocket
science it takes money it takes manpower
it takes technology but mostly what it
takes is to grow a pair and lead and I
think that Carly Fiorina if I may so I
want to say so respectfully is fine also
uh number five Daniel Cormier a lot of
ladies like like him so he's uh he's the
current UFC light heavyweight champion
another big dude
yes actually is not that big not that
big for a heavyweight the guys make me
fight as a mini he's scary no he's about
510 five nine Oh fighting heavyweights
and he fought at five at 205 and and won
the title there and then moved up so
right now he's the current lineal light
heavyweight champion and UFC heavyweight
champion and he's a former Olympian he's
one of the main commentators on ESPN it
was Fox Sports 1 I think now over there
at ESPN episode 363 I didn't think he
was going to come on the show and we've
been very fortunate to have a lot of
people who are not necessarily
conservatives not necessarily
politically minded come on the show and
in every now and then it's a crapshoot
what I really liked about Daniel Cormier
not only was he funny obviously I mean
people know he's very charismatic but he
was very vulnerable so there's a moment
there if you watch where he talks about
how scared he was before he absolutely
blitzed stipa Miocic
to win the title and he talks about this
moment of the excuses he was making for
himself
beforehand and I think it's something
you don't often see because when you're
doing the UFC countdowns right you're
trying to intimidate the opponent and
often when you're going on podcasts
you're trying to promote something he
didn't have anything to promote we
didn't need to pull anything out of him
politically socially I just just wanted
to hear what it was like to be Daniel
Cormier what it was like to win that
title and man it was it was it was a we
were
fortunate to get a whole nerble Daniel
Cormier who was just completely candid
can't go how did you do it did you
always believe and know that you were
going to be here what's that like what
are the doubts like along that path huh
you know man the crazy thing is it's
like when you when you deal with a lot
of these things that I've dealt with you
know especially the tragedies in life
you can either suck it up or you can say
you know what my journeys done you know
I knew that the best way to honor all
the people that I've lost especially
Kaden was to do something truly truly
special so use it as a motivating factor
in my life and that's what I've done I
feel like all the the the near the the
very close calls I had would becoming
the best led to that moment on them on
July 7th our July 9th when I fought
steeping oh come on that's a big
leverage we could give it to give or
take a couple of days I have a lot of
things going on and also Friday I'm
trying to really make myself seem more
busy than I am but I really did know the
date I did know we did you guys called
yeah you know we I doubt myself you know
I'm like man 39 years old you know you
know what the craziest thing was like
before the fight with Steve a being that
he was the guy that defended the belt
three times he's the most successful
heavyweight champ of all time yeah I'm
in the back in the locker room and I'm
walking back and forth and these are
thoughts of them have it to myself
because my coaches and teammates are all
excited I'm telling myself when I lose
I'm 39 years old I'm done with this I'm
never fighting again I don't need to
deal with this anxiety it's over I was
like I was like trying to give myself
reasons why he's gonna lose the fight
it was like what is going on number four
not as tough as Daniel Cormier senator
Ted Cruz the first the first episode 122
I think and then it was yeah then 271
he's been on a few times but
particularly the first one and the
reason for this was the first time he
came on I was after Carly Fiorina he was
a favorite I think at this point to
become president not a favorite but it
was between him and Donald Trump that
the lion head
and it was aside detectors that no one
had seen before we got so many comments
I used to hate Ted Cruz and then I saw
this and I really just actually a
likable guy and that's that's one thing
I think that this show is provided or at
least I'm really grateful that we try to
provide the opportunity to guests to let
their freak flag fly right that's that's
the opportunity for Ted Cruz I know he
has to go on a debate and he has to be
professional he has to be buttoned up
and unfortunately he has like an audio
graphic memory is what I've heard work
that's why everything sounds like it's
but he's just that way you need when we
talked to him off air
he said well next time when maybe we
could
there's someone hurt insulting here ah
is this being recorded or never recorded
you're on candid camera
okay well that's creepy but the first
interview episode 122 he still he was
actually a lot funnier than most people
thought he would be and he was a lot
more relaxed and that actually I think
changed well I know changed quite a few
public opinions about him this was at
the time you know the Bernie bros and
sort of the alt-right Pepe the Frog and
Ted Cruz wasn't really being examined by
a lot of people so it was interesting to
me at that time to see that shift it
doesn't pass a sniff test because either
way it's a moment of silence do you yell
praise Jesus praise Jesus praise Jesus
during remember and stay silence because
I told you to shut up look a moment of
silence is not that complicated to
figure out you're funny you're funny
you're good let that show a little more
in the debates I think people want to
see that from you because you're good at
it
and I dig it well thank you Stephen
we're doing it all the time when I when
I'm on the trail when we're doing town
halls this is what we're doing the media
doesn't show it right as we move closer
to the election we'll communicate
directly but but I'll give you something
that was just a week ago I was up in New
Hampshire did a breakfast meeting and at
the end of it they asked me about my
favorite movie my favorite movie is The
Princess Bride oh we're going to
disagree on that one but go ahead well
well then you may not like what I'm
gonna say next but a little bit of
prodding they got me to recreate the
entire scene where miracle max is is
resuscitating the Dread Pirate Roberts
and so if you want to google and see me
doing in pressure
of Billy Crystal and Carol Kane and Cary
Elwes and Mandy Patinkin that happened a
week ago on New Hampshire television and
if you want to link to it my guess is
people may chuckle but I will give one
defense of myself all right
a good impression is good a bad
impression is better people laugh much
more - bad impression and I do bad
impressions very well ok
Thank You senator then number three
actually was Joe Rogan episode was it
123 Joe Rogan I think it's episode 123
you can also find it on YouTube if
you're if you're watching this of course
and again send your favorite guests to
us just in the comment section or you
can tweet it and we'll see who we can
get on the show sometimes they don't
want to come on the show I don't you
know but here's why with Joe Rogan this
actually came this happened on the heels
of an appearance I made in the Joe Rogan
podcast and the appearance that's now be
viral where we talked about marijuana in
my position I don't want to get it as my
position is I don't care if you want to
smoke pot I I don't care if you want to
get high I couldn't care I don't think
that states not only should legalize
whatever medical marijuana if they want
to legalize it do whatever you just know
the ramifications and just don't tell me
it cures cancer that's all that's all if
States want to do that's my opinion
legalize correct yes yes I actually
honestly if a state wants to legalize
heroin constitutionally I find it hard
to argue against that's truly I don't
like heroin personally anyway so Joe
Rogan is not from God got into on the
show it became pretty heated and I know
he didn't mean for it to be heated and I
didn't want for it to be heated and
after that he was really great he's
always been so gracious as a host Joe
Rogan and um the reason this one when he
came on my show meant a lot he doesn't
go on a lot of people shows beat the
next day and he did not have to do this
he released this apology on Instagram
because he didn't feel good about how
our interaction went and he had he did
not need to do that I think it it wasn't
nearly as hostile as people wanted it to
be and that's why I went viral and the
reason him coming on the show I think is
is important it means a lot to me is
that sometimes public perception isn't
reality
after that I've done is show a few times
and they've always been fun I've always
had a good time with Joe and I like him
a lot and I respect him a lot as a
person and as a
I mean he's a trailblazer for podcasting
so I think for a lot of people they
thought that they had seen a feud and
for him to come on the show the next day
and explained that there wasn't he
didn't need to apologize it's not
because he apologized it didn't warrant
an apology from him but the fact that he
kind of said you know what listen I
realize you know you're in a place where
a lot of people disagree with you you're
used to kind of having to protect
yourself be combative and I didn't feel
good about putting in that position he
didn't do anything wrong but it was cool
to me and I hope important to the viewer
to see that sometimes a lot of these
feuds a lot of the gossip that you read
it's it's not real life and so here you
go just a brief clip from from Joe Rogan
who was very very gracious and has done
a lot for the program I don't think
you're conservative at all but I think
you're a free speech and a free-thinking
advocate which kind of eliminates you
from today's regressive left isn't that
bizarre I mean the when I was a kid my
parents were hippies and I grew up
thinking that the left was all the
people that were trying to stop this
unjust war in Vietnam and you know they
were trying to enable the civil rights
movement to succeed and enable free
speech and enable people to speak freely
right that's just not the case anymore
we're in some weird down is up and up is
down time yeah and for people like
myself who do have a lot of left-wing
ideas you know who do support gay
marriage who do support so many what you
would consider left ideas yeah you find
yourself in this this strange place
where you're so I'm so opposed right to
so much of these attacks on free speech
and so much of the greteman I don't want
to call it bullying because it's more of
a mob mentality thing it's kind of scary
like the Berkeley thing with Milo was
scary yeah you know and this
mischaracterize mixed
mischaracterization of his positions on
things is scary they making it out like
he's this evil hate monger who wants
genocide right and this is all just to
justify some of the crazy things that
they're doing smashing Starbucks windows
lighting cop cars on fire you know all
this chaos that you're seeing what
that's being perpetrated by the left
someone like myself I cannot identify
with that I do not understand it and it
puts at odds
but you know I don't not like a man
without a country now after that I'm
pretty sure he smoked weed he would tell
you himself yeah number two Ralph
Macchio episode 336 this is why you know
at one point if you'd have had Ralph
Macchio not like at one point before
Desperate Housewives if you were to say
Teri Hatcher people like well that that
person from Lois and Clark but then she
became an a-lister again with with with
Desperate Housewives yeah I mean Dean
Cain completely overshadows arenas yeah
Dean Cain is just I mean he's he's he's
prettier than Teri Hatcher if that's
possible it is possible I said it I
stand by it
he's so he's so good-looking that they
relabeled on Netflix
Lois and Clark lesbian cosplay it's hard
to find so Ralph Macchio at one point if
you'd say Ralph Macchio I come on he was
a big star in the 80s and 90s but Cobra
Kai had come out on YouTube red okay and
the reason this is number two and why
it's why it's so important this is a
pivotal moment for this show and I think
for online entertainment in general for
a lot of YouTube people out there for
podcasters out there for people who've
come so it's this race to the middle so
people talk about you know you used to
have Johnny Carson right then he was the
only late-night show at that point and
then it got split and you had Letterman
and Leno and then he had shows after
them and then it was okay Letterman Leno
and Conan and the numbers went down and
now you have Colbert and Kimmel and and
Fallon and Conan and I don't know
nobody's little has a show but the point
is and then you have Samantha be in
Trevor Noah
and so the networks were there used to
only be three then cable fragmented it
and their numbers have been doing this
at the same time people who started
online YouTube I mean you can go check
out her I think my YouTube channels been
up since 2006 we didn't really upload
anything back then we've been doing this
and they've been doing this and it's
this race to the middle when we started
this show you know we there are a lot of
people who wouldn't come on the show and
rightfully so
and if you still don't want if they
still won rightfully so I don't but I
wouldn't but it was so Ralph Macchio is
I don't I don't know his political
persuasions at all but what was
interesting to me was at this point in
time we've said we're never going to
have the ratings of American Idol or
Johnny Carson again well actually they
do
exist they exist in the show Cobra Kai
YouTube Bret I think was 30-something
million yeah a show I is millions 36
million people it's a good show great
show it's a really really good show so
not only do I love the show Cobra Kai I
highly recommend it it's one of the few
sort of comedies in recent memory that I
can say works really well not only am i
Ralph Macchio fan not only was he a good
guest but this was an interesting flip
where at one point people who would be
on ABC CBS NBC wouldn't come on a show
like this and now they would kill for
the ratings that Cobra Kai was getting
and Ralph Macchio was a lead and because
he saw the value in reaching out to the
audience who supported him with Cobra
Kai he came on this show so what really
was a changing of the guard so episode
336 right and one thing to a moment here
that I really enjoyed was there vitalize
Ralph Macchio's a really good actor it's
overshadowed by a lot he's a really
really good actor and so I wanted to ask
him about a very specific moment that
struck a chord with me in Karate Kid and
he told me off air that he really
appreciated it and I know it touched him
and I'm very grateful that he's been on
the show Ralph Macchio it's such a great
job people who don't know what they're
watching because a lot of people II just
watch films and I see it from the
entertainment standpoint that's one shot
you're conveying a lot of different
emotions anger - helplessness - desk
wanting to go to a karate school the
losing it in your voice I always watch
that scene and said people don't realize
how well perform the scene how many
takes did that taken how did he get into
that headspace because it really is
something incredible to watch well first
of all thank you very much and it was
nice - it was nice to just revisit that
audio-wise because you know we watch
this film a bunch of time over over the
years that's the great Randy Heller also
playing mrs. Larusso who is a nice
without making spoilers it's a nice
Easter egg and I just gave it away right
in our series and we're hoping to to
have that role and other actors from
back then back in the future of the
Cobra Kai show thee you know the scene
we did it a bunch of times some of it
was cuz the camera you know some of it
was on
me some of it was on the camera you know
we didn't get it perfect each every
single time and I think if I actually
watch that take if you really analyze it
there's one point where the Steadicam
just does a little bit of a of a a my
there should be back there we go okay
there's that wonderful point okay so
continuous in the camera got a little
crooked right so the camera got a little
little you know a little wobble in it
and by technical perfection standard she
would say let's go again we have a
little bit but the performance credit
the director um you know you go with who
you always go in performance because
that stuff falls away right you know
that stuff you don't notice um I think
that that that scene did have a lot of
levels I mean the whole I hate this bike
this stupid but that was all John
avildsen saying when you walk up you
know I think he was trying to help me
get to that level yeah and he had me
walk down and keep throwing keep
throwing it in there he said go back to
it again and he had the camera rolling
and I I had to do it like three and four
times sometimes per take just pick it up
sometimes he said take it out again and
do it again and he was I think what he
was doing I'm sure what he was doing was
getting me to that place of frustration
and build all that level of emotion the
the line when he says none of that none
of none I the white a real school was
basically Ralph Macchio forgetting the
line hearing it out you're funny we
quote that in our house all the time
when I was a kid like if we had a proper
take karate ma not at the Y at a good
school and it was right no it's sort of
a lying the house I think it's it's a
it's a credit to all of us working
together well-written scene of fantastic
director a beautiful and and wonderful
actress to play opposite we had a great
chemistry together and and it's just one
of those that that we call it on film
you know it doesn't always happen and
he's still cute as a button Ralph
Macchio I bet you Elisabeth Shue still
get herself a piece of that know number
one the number one interview all right
let me see it let's see if you can guess
I want put in the comment section your
guess before the head yeah don't skip it
yeah don't skip ahead cheater guess
five four okay you've guessed then come
back and let me know if you were right
the number one interview that I've ever
conducted in this show that stands out
is not a celebrity at all
Stephen Willeford yeah I know a lot of
people's a lot of your poets probably
saying who so this was they were far
deadlier actually in the parklands
shooting one of the worst shootings and
mass shootings in modern history wasn't
southern one Springs outside of San
Antonio where a guy opened fire on a
church and he was stopped by a man who
was an NRA certified instructor with an
ar-15 that man was Stephen Willeford
that is you a badass man he's been you
so he he actually wasn't doing a whole
lot of media he did one local media
appearance because someone was an actual
friend of his who he worked with but
this was the first and as far as I know
it the only one for a long time as far
as now I'm now my mouth is getting dry
so here Hollyn listen to this this is
this is this this is this is what
happens when it's live that's ASMR I
don't know what that means stop being
disgusting so Stephen Stephen Willeford
turned out he was a fan of the show
I think his I think his daughter was a
mug club member and they reached out to
us because we reached out and said hey
listen I I know you're just being
bombarded he was holed up in his house
effectively because press wouldn't leave
him alone at that point but they didn't
really want to tell the story they
wanted to see kind of what what had
happened but no one in the press was
really covering an NRA certified
instructor took out a guy with an ar-15
and sure enough sure as they came the
press was gone really really quickly
that was a story that like a fought in
the wind it was gone and his daughter I
believe spoke with our Booker on the
show and said you know it's really
important that he go on a program that
where I just that he'll be represented
fairly and allowed to speak and I really
do think as someone who's watched the
show I think this would be good for him
and so he did he came on the show and
that was you know it's the reason it
meant something to me was not because it
was an exclusive scoop I mean that's
that's always a nice I'm not gonna lie
and say that it wasn't a big deal that
we had this exclusive but it was really
hard for me
I remember going into its saying I don't
wanna do the Barbara Walters thing I
don't want I don't want to make him cry
this is a guy who's just been through a
traumatic event who just shot somebody
who just had friends of his died and I
don't want to exploit it but they did
reach out to us and say this would be
good for him to get this out and finally
speak about it and it was a real
challenge to try and balance this
interview and he started crying on air
when describing this at one point and it
kind of reminded me of Tom Hanks and
punch line where he's on stage asking
someone to help him and so I wanted to
jump in and help him where I could but
give him the floor where he needed it
and a lot of people reached out and said
hey we really appreciate that you did
that and that we were able to hear his
story because no one had heard it from
the media yet and his family actually
sent me some very nice messages and they
were they were very grateful so it was
hard for me not to cry if you go back
and watch the full interview episode 257
Stephen Willeford right after the
Sutherland spring shooting it was very
difficult for me to keep my composure to
try and hey Melissa you know this is
what happens sometimes in life you're
never prepared for it you just have to
do it there most things if you think
about turning moments in your life
you're not prepared you've just got to
step up and that's what happened here
with Stephen Willeford I did the best
that I could and seeing him at the end
of this interview when he was going
through these harrowing detail an item
air and he was crying on air I was very
emotional but then getting him to laugh
a little bit and that's what his family
said you know meant a lot um that's what
I can do every now and then and it meant
a lot for for me to do and it's
something I'll never forget
Stephen Wilford to have that frame of
mind like you said that foresight I know
people are going to be asking this come
with your NRA instructor training
military background because most people
would not think to look for this to be
aware of your surroundings it is it is
remarkable well that's what I'm telling
you I can't I can't explain the clarity
of mind that I had I can't explain it
and and and not only back but I was
using the neighbor's Dodge pickup truck
he had a four
we'll drive Dodge pickup truck in his
driveway and I was using it all I had
all he had four shot for me as my head
because I was behind the truck and using
it for cover okay and we exchanged fire
and he hit the neighbors car's
windshield he hit the neighbor's house
and he got into the vehicle and I fired
again and he fired two more shots
through his side actually he shard fired
two shots through a side window first
and it put Otis the two distinct pistol
shots coming through the sides of the
window and I fired my 15 again and it
took the window down it fell
according to media people like you
people as pure hearted and as capable
don't exist and it is an unbelievable
story we've I mean it you're in it now
see but you've you're a huge moment in
history what you did ok can I think
can I say something being and I I don't
feel comfortable sad just anywhere but
maybe with you guys if I had run out of
the house and maybe this is a political
plug or whatever but if I had run out of
the house with a pistol and faced
bulletproof vests and Kevlar helmets it
might have been futile right I know I
and I ran out with an ar-15 and that's
what he was shooting the place up with
right and it's and I hate to politicize
that but that's reality I was terrified
by the way that's what makes you brave
you know I my dad tell me that when I
was young you know what the definition
of he had that conversation with me he
said you know what brave is I said it
means not being afraid he said no it
means doing the right thing in the face
of being afraid no one expects you to be
fearless no one expects you to go out
there and be John Rambo I would imagine
that if it were me
I'd be yelling to my wife to get my
brown pants I would have lost myself
laughter hopefully uh made your day a
little brighter and he's been he's been
on the show since by the way also Steven
Willeford so we made sure to follow up
we weren't just a lot of these you know
kind of like David hog with those people
then all of a sudden everyone who
supports David hog where they where have
they gone gone so he has to start now
bashing Nancy Pelosi know we've had
Steven Willeford on and if ever he has
something need to promote anything so he
doesn't really often request being on
but when he does we have him on the
program and he's become I'd like that I
would say that certainly him or his
family members have become friends and
we're really fortunate to know them so
those are the top ten interviews that
stick out in my mind that I've conducted
that I've enjoyed the most or that have
impacted me the most comment again let
me know what you think what what
interview stand out to you what what
were your favorite or which interviews
maybe made an impact on you that changed
your course of thinking or maybe
inspired you to to do something that you
thought you would never do comment I
want to hear from you because that's a
big part of this show a big part are the
guests and man they change people's
lives myself and everyone in the studio
included
thank you for watching we're gonna see
you tomorrow with a normal show or maybe
a super video knows if you like this
video you first up should probably seek
counseling but you should subscribe or
hit the notification barrel or watch one
of these videos that's playing what the
truth is I don't know what any of that
means anymore
if you try and subscribe it's a
notification bell you won't be notified
and if you try to click one of these
videos it's just going to take you to
BuzzFeed boldly fat frauds as they get
carried out of their houses were led to
break down the north wall and they get
carried out in the land well tarp I
don't know what's happening on YouTube I
know what's happening with mug Club
ladders credit.com slash month let me
get to watch The Daily Show one hour
every single day not just clips along
with like fifteen other shows for 69
dollars annually if your student and/or
veteran or military and you get to keep
us here on YouTube for free because we
can we can irritate them by your support
it's worth it right